hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video hier
spielen heute mal wieder das spiel
yoopress debatten dabei geht es darum
dass wir zwei auswahlmöglichkeiten haben
und zwar wenn wir den knopf drücken
geschehen beide sachen und wenn ihr den
knopf nicht drücken dann geschieht halt
keine von in sachen und wieso drücke ich
jetzt rechte maustaste ich zeige euch
einfach wieder funktioniert anhand von
spielen selbst also wenn wir den knopf
drücken spüren wir einerseits gar keine
sorte mehr von schmerz andererseits
haben wir eine sehr große chance um früh
in unserem leben zu sterben
ich würde nicht drücken jetzt klicken
wir beispielsweise auf nord und jetzt
sehen wir 61 prozent haben nicht den
knopf gedrückt das heißt wir sind in der
mehrheit wenn wir jetzt in der
minderheit gewesen wären hätte ich
gesagt bei jedem mal wo ich quasi bei
weniger leuten bin die die autor
möglichkeit genommen klatsche ich mir
eine und das machen wir ab jetzt yuan
money for doing something i love but i
would probably star des song die
apokalypse okay das heißt wir bekommen
geld für etwas was wir gerne tun also
beiden seiten wir bekommen geld fürs
essen allerdings es ist total unlogisch
dass die zombie apokalypse entsteht ich
glaube ich will auch so ein mensch eine
zombie apokalypse cool fand also drücke
ich definitiv den knopf 58% heftpreis
debatten okay das ist meist wir sind
schon wieder in der mehrheit auf der
einen seite werden wir nie wieder
werbung sehen in unserem kompletten
leben auf der anderen seite sind
afrikanische killerbienen vor unserer
tür also ich würd ich würde definitiv
nicht drücken 65 prozent haben nicht
gedrückt alter freunde tom ford mit
migros wenn wir jetzt den knopf drücken
haben wir einerseits einen zukunfts
kalender der uns alle sachen anzeigt von
freunden und familie also wann die
sterben
mit anderen leuten schluss machen und so
weiter und so fort auf der anderen seite
kann man allerdings nichts gegen diese
ereignisse unternehmen aber ich glaube
so auch wenn man das wissen würde wenn
ich jetzt beispielsweise wüsste knie
irgend ein kumpel von mir stirbt
übermorgen dann würde ich mich jetzt
extra noch richtig viel mit ihm befassen
auch wenn es sich jetzt nicht verhindern
kann also ich würde definitiv den knopf
drücken 62 prozent haben den knopf
gedrückt alter freunde
ich bin immer in der mehrheit ich glaube
diese sache hatten wir schon mal und
zwar man wird nie wieder krank werden in
seinem kompletten leben allerdings wird
man das die ganze zeit alleine sein das
ist mir scheißegal wird ihn obwohl krank
werden heißt er denn auch so was krasses
wie aids und krebs und so ich würde
trotzdem nicht den knopf drücken und ich
bin schon wieder in der mehrheit alter
freunde dann mache ich so eine challenge
dass immer wenn ich falsch lege mir eine
clutch und an passiert einfach nicht man
würde täglich 1000 dollar bekommen
allerdings müsste man eine person töten
die eine gute person ist junge 1000 euro
täglich
das heißt man verdient dann irgendwie
365.000 euro im jahr das heißt in drei
jahren ist man millionär und das dann
sein leben lang wird man dafür umbringen
2000 jahre später also ich hab jetzt
gedrückt dass ich definitiv nicht dafür
umbringen würde und ich bin schon wieder
in der mehrheit allerdings diesmal ganz
knapp mit nur 53 prozent man muss nie
wieder für essen bezahlen allerdings
muss man immer nur super essen ich würde
auf gar keinen fall drücken man die
bücher wieder in der mehrheit bei dieser
sache wer einerseits kompletter
weltfrieden und andererseits wer man
allerdings übels gelangweilt die noch
nie ein mensch langweilig gewesen sein
war
alter schwede das sind jetzt diese
typischen leute die sich glaube ich
opfern würden für die welt also ich
würde sagen ja ich drücke drauf und ich
bin ich bin in der minderheit hat sagen
doch tatsächlich mehr leute ich mir
jetzt lieber nicht langweilig als dass
sich alle auf der welt frieden den
kommentaren stadtrat auch sofort kein
opfer wurden press net button und so das
ist echt freunde die wir den nicht
gedrückt haben [ __ ] you kill the happy
ist hier of your life but the xx of the
world we be completed also man hätte ein
jahr kompletten übels glückliches leben
allerdings ein halbes jahr danach
komplett scheiße
ich würde definitiv nicht drücken 64
prozent haben nicht gedrückt dass es
auch wieder toll da sind wir nämlich
wieder direkt wieder eine mehrheit you
make me and selling matthew j cancer the
[ __ ] es ist wieder diese geld sache auf
der einen sache so richtig gegelten auf
der andern seite richtige scheiße also
ich würde sage ich nicht drücken weil so
vieles mehr geld jetzt auch nicht mehr
sie sind schon wieder eine mehrheit und
zwar zwei drittel haben eingedrückt bei
diesen knopf hat man einerseits den
perfektesten körper denen es gilt
allerdings andererseits riecht man nach
müll also das ist schon schwierig ich
würde jetzt sagen ich drücke den knopf
und benutzt einfach perfekt
allerdings würde ich mal sagen dass es
nicht weggeht das heißt ich denke ich
für den knappen nicht drücken und
einfach trainieren wählen das heißt dort
72 prozent haben eingedrückt einerseits
kann man schlafen wann immer man will
andererseits wird man gezwungen jede 20
minuten aufzustehen ich würde definitiv
nicht den knopf drücken und ich kann
euch jetzt schon sagen dass ich in der
mehrheit bin freunde 62% mord ich bin
immer in der mehrheit ich war bisher nur
einmal daneben
damit will ich das video auch schon
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen schreibt mir mal bitte
jeder in die kommentare an welcher
situation hier anders gedrückt hätte als
ich also wo ihr eine andere meinung
vertreten hätte dann seht ihr auch schon
hier ich habe hier ein bisschen
umgeräumt ich habe hier seine ablage hin
gemacht und da kommt jetzt fallstudien
sachen drauf und die hinten habe ich so
ein komisches holzstöcke den ball da bin
ich zum thema wir sehen uns herein